it's been good to have a break, honestly from
the craziness of American politics for a few
days.
I completely checked out over the Thanksgiving
break here in the United States.
One of the very clear things that happened
while we were gone is that Donald Trump has
started to do just a really good job as president
of the United States.
Just kidding.
I hope you didn't zone out.
I'm kidding about that.
What happened is that the legal news is sort
of starting to tighten around Rudy Giuliani.
It was pretty clear really more than a year
ago that the former New York city mayor was
trouble for Trump.
He got pulled off TV appearances for awhile.
He is now back front and center because of
his involvement in the Ukraine fiasco and
now it really could be a tragic end for Rudy
Giuliani in the Greek tragedy sense.
I use that term up for Donald Trump's maybe
personal lawyer.
I guess at this point, we don't really know
what the relationship is between Rudy and
Trump.
Two of Rudy's associates have been arrested,
loved Parness and Igor Fruman.
One of them love Parness is cooperating and
says, as I told you early last week, that
he can directly and specifically implicate
Republican Congressman Devin.
Newness in the Ukraine fiasco.
We may have more news about that later this
week.
A grand jury has now issued a subpoena for
documents related to Rudy Giuliani's international
consulting as a, as he calls it, which is
one of those innocuous terms, international
consulting, I call it influence pet pedaling
and negotiating bribery and smears, and that
relates to a whole bunch of possible crimes
that Rudy may have committed.
We're looking at money laundering, wire fraud,
campaign finance violations, making false
statements, obstruction of justice, violations
of the foreign agents, registration act, Farrah
as it's known.
We're talking here about both criminal and
congressional investigations into Rudy Giuliani's
work and the things that he's done, and Rudy,
of course, denies everything.
Always telling TMZ.
TMZ found him at an airport, I think over
the Thanksgiving break and he said, Oh, there's
no way that I'm going to end up in prison.
But remember Roger Stone told me the same
thing when I interviewed him about a year
and a half ago.
He was of course recently found guilty on
seven counts and will be sentenced in a couple
of months heading to prison, potentially up
to 20 years.
Realistically, much, much less.
What this increasingly is going to be about.
So to set the stage for you for the next month,
year, few years, I don't really know how long
this is going to go.
Um, what is going to determine the future
for Rudy Giuliani is whether Trump abandons
him or sticks with them because that's the
trend as we've already seen happen.
Sometimes people, uh, throw Trump under the
bus and then Trump abandons them.
Michael Cohen is one example, but maybe that's
not exactly the way it happened.
Maybe it's more that Trump makes it clear
he's not going to stand by the person and
then they throw Trump under the bus.
But the point is you have the, on the one
hand, people like Michael Cohen, on the other
hand, you've got the people like Paul Manafort
and Roger Stone who have at least seemingly
remained loyal to Donald Trump during their
prosecutions.
And it's still plausible that a pardon is
coming for them.
We don't know yet, but it is certainly plausible.
The real factor that will determine Rudy Giuliani's
future is not, did he break the law or didn't
he?
Did he act immorally or didn't he?
Did he do this or did he do that?
Rudy is privileged such that he is not part
of the justice system for the most of us.
He's part of a different justice system where
it's who your friends are, whether it's does
the president remain loyal to you?
That is what will determine the future for
Rudy Giuliani.
He has a get out of jail free card.
Not in a proverbial sense, in a literal sense.
It's called a presidential pardon on corporate
media.
They're staging these dumb little debates
about, Oh, does Rudy risk having his reputation
tarnished by this?
Uh, a scandal?
First of all, that assumes that Rudy had a
good reputation before this.
Forget about that for now.
That's a debate for a different day.
Rudy Giuliani has become a sort of villain
of the worst intersection of influence, pedaling
vulture capitalism and international corruption
and has made it clear that what his values
are are unquenchable thirst for proximity
to power money.
He will use any associations at all to further
those goals.
It doesn't matter what it means for the United
States as a country, and that's how you end
up in a position to have today in and day
out on national media, defend the indefensible,
which are the actions of Donald Trump.
The next couple of weeks, particularly with
the upcoming impeachment hearings, there are
more starting Wednesday, we'll be covering
them live on YouTube.
They will be illuminating.
I predict about Rudy Giuliani's role and we'll
catch up about it later this week or early
next when we actually get to see what is said.
At this week's impeachment hearings